لذلك أنت تعرف أن أحد الأسباب التي
تجعل الناس يختارون الفنادق على airbnbs
هي وسائل الراحة مثل تنظيف الغرف ،
هل تعتقد أن تقليص هذا الأمر
وغيره من وسائل الراحة قد يؤدي في النهاية إلى الإضرار
بأعمال الفندق على المدى الطويل.  إن
التضحية بالميزة التنافسية
التي يتمتعون بها على المنزل يبقى كما تعلم ،
وعندما تقول في منزل
عائلي تحصل على نوع من
المطبخ المتميز ، ربما تحصل على مساحة أكبر قليلاً
ولكن ليس لديك هذا النوع من
الخدمة اليومية التي يقدمها العديد من الأشخاص
أتوقع مع الفنادق إذا كانت الفنادق تتخلى عن
ذلك أه قد يجدون أن الكثير من
مسافريهم يدركون جيدًا ما هي
فائدة البقاء هنا مقابل الذهاب
مع Airbnb أو VRBO لتبدأ
بأه أعتقد أن سبب قيام الفنادق بذلك
في  المكان الأول هو أنهم يجرون
نوعًا من التجارب المستمرة من نوع ما
لمعرفة مدى
تقدير المسافرين حقًا للخدمة المستمرة ، وهم
يجدون أن الأشخاص الجيدين قد
يتساوى في تفضيل جميع الأشياء ، فأنت تعلم أن
الغرف نظيفة يوميًا  ليس بالضرورة على
استعداد لدفع المزيد مقابل ذلك ، نعم ، أعني
أنك ذكرت أسعار غرف الفنادق ، لذا
أعتقد أن السؤال إذن هو هل نرى
أننا مع وسائل الراحة المنخفضة هذه ، هل
نشهد أسعارًا أقل الآن أو هل تعتقد
في وقت ما في المستقبل أن هذا يمكن أن
يحدث
أه لسنا أتمنى لو كان لدينا
غرف فندقية إخبارية أفضل ، ارتفعت الأسعار بنسبة ثمانية في
المائة مقارنة بالعام الماضي بزيادة 20
مقارنة بما قبل الجائحة وفي العديد من
الأسواق خاصة أماكن مثل لاس فيغاس
ميامي ، ترى معدلات أعلى
سواء  أو ليس هذا كما تعلم ، يؤدي إلى قيام
الفنادق بخفض الأسعار في المستقبل مقابل
خدمة تنظيف أقل أعتقد أن هذا
يظل سؤالًا مفتوحًا ولكن أعتقد
أننا لا نرى تخفيضات في
الأسعار التي أدركت الفنادق
أنها لم يستمتع بها الناس
لم يكن الناس بالضرورة على
استعداد لدفع المزيد مقابل المزيد من التنظيف